y lo hacemos con nuestra revista de
prensa de la mano Cómo no de Marta Moya
Marta Buenos días para usted un saludo
Hola Ángela Buenos días bueno Marta voy
a pedirle que demos inicio al primer
tema vamos a empezar con un reportaje
que publica el medio político y que
titula la población civil se ha
convertido en Nuevo objetivo de los
jóvenes activistas climáticos si Ángela
es un reportaje Que firma call matizen y
dice que los activistas climáticos ya no
solo lanzan botes de tomate contra obras
de arte ni interrumpes ni interrumpe en
eventos deportivos o cortan carreteras o
depósitos de gasolina sino que una nueva
técnica es afectar a la población civil
que posee carros de Gran envergadura y
pinchar los neumáticos de esos carros en
Bruselas un grupo llamado extintores de
neumáticos dice haber desarmado 194
coches de este tipo entre la capital
Bruselas y la ciudad de Gante cloth uno
de ellos de este grupo de extintores de
dice textualmente en el reportaje no
queremos que piensen que pueden comprar
un auto grande y simplemente disfrutar
de la vida e ignorar lo que sucede en el
mundo
la técnica la dinámica de estos jóvenes
es llegar frente a estos carros dejan un
papel en el cristal frontal que dice no
te lo tomes como algo personal no eres
Nuestro objetivo si no es el carro y
después pinchan estos neumáticos dicen
además que no atacan a autos que tengan
asientos para niños o que tengan
stickers de personas con discapacidad o
etiquetas médicas además sostiene este
reportaje de político que este grupo
exhintorias de neumático tiene una
página web anónima donde Pues están las
bases de sus acciones y afirman haber
dañado más de 11.000 vehículos todo
terreno en 17 países en todo el mundo
Esta no es una técnica novedosa esto
nació de manera aislada en 2007 en
Suecia sin embargo ahora pues se ha
expandido en todo el mundo sobre todo
después de que en 2022 la compra de
estos vehículos todo terreno
experimentará un récord en ventas Ángela
Bueno también en relación a este tema
Marta del periódico británico de Garden
publica un sondeo que realiza en
exclusiva en siete países europeos y de
ahí se deriva que la sociedad está
dispuesta sí a tomar medidas contra el
cambio climático pero no se afectan
mucho sus vidas personales Entonces qué
Así es Ángela Es un sondeo de yugoff que
ha hecho a mil personas en siete países
de la Unión Europea para evaluar como la
sociedad aborda los efectos del cambio
climático entonces lo que decíamos
cuando las medidas son colectivas y no
tienen implicaciones muy evidentes sobre
las vidas personales de estos hay un
consenso claro sobre que hay que actuar
sin embargo cuando empiezan a tocar
aspectos más controvertidos
el compromiso sobre la acción climática
ya es un poco menor
este artículo de The Guardian que recoge
este sondeón exclusivo dice que hay una
horquilla entre el 60 y el 81%
a favor de que la población europea está
preocupada sobre el cambio climático hay
un consenso amplio sobre que hay que
promover programas gubernamentales sobre
plantación de árboles contra la compra
de plásticos de un solo uso contra la
limitación del consumo de carne o hacer
que los hogares sean energéticamente más
eficientes sin embargo en lo referido a
limitar la compra de ropa nueva prohibir
el consumo de leche de origen animal el
cambio obligatorio a vehículos
eléctricos no hay ningún tipo de
consenso ni siquiera para establecer
impuestos más elevados a los
combustibles fósiles y tampoco a la idea
de que hay que prohibir los carros en
las ciudades y solo se puede utilizar el
transporte público o andar sobre estos
temas Sólo hay un consenso del 35%
Ángela bueno su siguiente tema es
simplemente escabroso el periódico
español el país publica un artículo este
miércoles en el que titula que varias
ciudades de México es son el lugar donde
grupos de narcotraficantes están
experimentando la efectividad del
fentanilo y lo hacen con personas
adictas a las drogas sea Ángela Este es
un tema muy preocupante nos referimos a
las ciudades de Mexicali y Tijuana dos
urbes fronterizadas con Estados Unidos
donde se ha disparado en los últimos
años el consumo de fentanilo todo esto
según Víctor Clark citado por el
periódico el país que es el director del
centro binacional de Derechos Humanos
además estas urbes se han convertido en
laboratorios para que los carteles del
narcotráfico calculen las dosis que
puede soportar una persona para después
vender el fentanilo a un menor coste y
que este sea mucho más potente cuando
llega a Estados Unidos para ello
utilizan a personas con adicción a las
drogas y combinan con cocaína
metanfetaminas cristal heroína y después
estas personas desarrollan una cierta
tolerancia al fentanilo y es Entonces
cuando lo testean y lo venden hace unas
semanas el departamento de Estados de
estado de Estados Unidos dijo que está
experimentación humana era una realidad
y además el 14 de abril se publicó la
acusación contra los chapitos Los
herederos del imperio de la droga del
Chapo Guzmán que reflejan esto mismo
reflejan concretamente el caso de una
mujer que murió por sobredosis después
de que el cartel de los chapitos le
diera tres dosis de fentanilo que se
considera mortal además esto ha creado
también un problema en México donde el
consumo de estas sustancias sintética ha
crecido exponencialmente en los últimos
años aunque no se tienen datos concretos
de cómo ha sido la evolución dado que el
gobierno no emite datos oficiales sin
embargo sí que se ha desarrollado una
ley para castigar con hasta 15 años de
cárcel a los traficantes de precursores
sabe que nos refleja esto una pésima
política de manejo de las drogas de los
países y de América Latina Marta un tema
súper importante y Es que hoy es el 30
de aniversario mundial del día de la
libertad de prensa y vamos a tener una
invitada sobre este tema ha habido un
cambio de agenda pero pues usted tiene
la palabra para hablarnos de esta fecha
que hay que conmemorar con todo de la
inco Así es Ángela 30 años desde que la
organización de Naciones Unidas
decretara el día para la libertad de
prensa y hoy el reporteros Sin fronteras
ha publicado su informe anual sobre esta
cuestión basada en 180 países advierte
que la situación de la libertad de
prensa en el mundo está muy complicada y
se considera mala en siete de cada diez
países entre las amenazas comunes están
la desinformación la propaganda y el
desarrollo de la Inteligencia artificial
además el mapa de la de la libertad de
prensa que se establece por colores del
verde donde es mejor al rojo donde es
peor tiene más que nunca países en rojo
India Turquía tayikistán se han sumado a
la lista de países en rojo Oriente medio
sigue siendo la región del mundo donde
es más difícil ejercer el periodismo Por
otra parte en el continente americano
ningún país está en verde antes lo
estaba Costa Rica y por dar un ejemplo
muy claro Estados Unidos está en el
puesto número 45 en África senegal ha
descendido 31 puestos y túnez 27 y el
informe dice que en el mundo occidental
el panorama el panorama de medios es
mixto y además advierte de que la Unión
Europea también hay que tomar medidas
para defender esa libertad de prensa
frente a los continuos silenciamientos a
periodistas mire hay que decir lo que el
periodismo es una profesión que es
difícil ejercer en cualquier parte del
mundo y por diferentes razones por
supuesto que toda nuestra solidaridad y
nuestro apoyo para los compañeros que
están en los terrenos más difíciles y
nos traen las noticias gracias a usted
Marta gracias